so good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
and most warmly welcome to this press
conference of prime minister of finland
and president of the european commission
and the subject of this press conference
is finland's recovery and resilience
plan
we start with the remarks with prime
minister please
thank you so much it's been a great
pleasure to welcome the president of the
commission ursula vandalian to finland
we have a very useful discussion with
her this afternoon
we exchanged views on number of topical
issues
uh concerning europe a major focus of
discussion was how we can best work
towards screen and digital
transformation
in europe
finland has ambitious national goals in
terms of reaching climate neutrality and
boosting digital economy
and accordingly we want the eu to become
the world's most competitive and
socially inclusive climate neutral
economy
we discussed with ursula various aspects
of the fit455 legislative package that
the commission issued
last summer with the goal to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by at least 55
percent
by 2030.
finland supports rapid progress in
negotiations on the package the level of
ambition has to be maintained we
consider emissions trading to be
the main policy measure for achieving
the target
we also exchange views with ursula on
forestry and use new forest strategy
finland's approach towards forests and
forestry is a holistic one
we want to take into account
environmental economic and social
dimensions of sustainability and
recognize the overall potential of
forest and the forest sector
we also discussed autotopical issues
such as the need to move forward in
european defense cooperation
use recovery package is a key tool to
boost digital and korean transition
across the union
as you know major context of this visit
to helsinki is to getting insight into
finland's national recovery plan our
visit here in vtt serves to illustrate
one focus of finland's national recovery
plan
our recovery plan recognizes quantum
computing as one of
as one key aspect of technological
competitiveness in the future
we have just now had an opportunity to
learn more about bt's work to build
finland's first quantum computer
it is a good example on how they use
recovery package can support investment
to advance new technologies
investments in new technologies are
indeed essential to ensure not only the
recovery of our economies but at the
same time in the long term to renewal
our economies
i would like now to give the floor to
the president of the commission ursula
the floor is yours thank you very much
prime minister diazana thank you very
much for
the warm welcome you gave me and my
delegation today
and i would
very much thank you for the fascinating
visit here at vtt the
technical research center
um finland's first quantum computer i've
learned a lot today so that was really
informative
and i think
this is a perfect example for farsighted
investment here in finland we heard a
lot about it
and indeed we need to strengthen
europe's technological leadership
and thus create quality jobs that are
needed
and that is the spirit in which we
design next generation eu
the 800 billion
recovery fund
it is much more than simple recovery
we are reshaping our continent for
decades to come
we're making the green deal
a reality and we are also accelerating
digitalization in an unprecedented
manner
so i'm happy to announce that today
the euro european commission has decided
to give its green light
to finland's recovery and resilience
plan
this follows a thorough assessment and
an excellent cooperation
between our teams and i really want to
thank the sunnah for this excellent
cooperation it is outstanding we have
the comparison so thank you very much
for that
the plan includes reforms and investment
it will further accelerate finland's
outstanding
green and digital transitions
and i must say we applaud finland's
ambitious objective to be carbon neutral
by 2035 already
your recovery and resilience plan
will provide an important boost
to this important
goal
so if i look into the plan half of the
plan the finland's plan
is devoted to the green transition to
green projects 50
this is more than it would have been
necessary so you're overshooting
the necessary requirements and this is
outstanding
it includes spot-on measures
in each of the most polluting sectors
such as energy industry
transport and housing
it will invest in just to give a few
examples
low carbon hydrogen
in clean energy technologies
it will finance green transport
and very important roll out charging
points along the roads
for cars
it will for example replace oil boilers
with low or zero carbon heating system
so that is investing in the european
green deal at its best
the second objective we have in next
generation eu is the digital
and finland is already a leader in the
digital transition in the european union
and in the world
so now you devote 27
of the plan to support the digital
objectives
and this
for sure will help finland to sustain
its leading position
the plan will support research in 6g
artificial intelligence microelectronics
high-speed connectivity
and very pleased about your plan to
connect the rural areas that will
benefit from the investment in the
digital connectivity and digital rail
services for example
i also like very much that the plan will
help the public sector
to go more digital this is always needed
and it will equip finnish workers with
digital skills
they need to be ready for the future
but next generation u is not only about
investments the finished plan also
contains a range of crucial reforms
the plan anchors the
2035 carbon neutrality
goal into finnish law
the plan will phase out the use of coal
and make finland's tax policy greener
in other words there too this plan will
strengthen finland's position as green
front runner in the european union
and last but not least it is also very
good that your plan aims to strengthen
the national health system
we have learned our lessons from the
pandemic and we know how important it is
to invest in the healthcare sector so to
upgrade existing medical facilities
you will invest in the development of
ehealth
your plan will increase the number of
higher education
study places
and of course also address the shortage
of health workers
in the medium term
because investing in our future is
investing in our health and in the
health of the planet
so i have the pleasure to hand over now
the envelope that gives green light to
the finnish clan
thank you very much thank you
thank you so much
and we have time ursula a few questions
and we start with the wiley and kindly
represent yourself and your media before
making the question
from wiley
we have learned about a new data leak
pandora's papers revealing that
thousands of people are still using
taking advantage of tax havens even the
high-ranking politicians what is your
assessment about the situation and is
there something that eu or member states
could do in order to avoid
tax avoidance thank you
yes so
tax evasion and aggressive tax planning
is completely unacceptable
and
we have in the european union some of
the highest tax transparency standards
in the world
but as we see it's not enough more work
is needed
and that's why we will come forward with
a proposal on the misuse of shell
companies
for tax purposes and this will be done
till the end of the year so we'll come
with an answer to the obvious problems
that are still out there
well of course uh tax avoidance is a
serious problem and i want to thank the
journalists
that
came this avoidance's delight so thanks
to those journalists and i'm very happy
that the commission is also doing its
best
to to make sure that these kind of
elements are being
ripped out of our system so so we are
taking this issue very seriously and we
are working with the commission and with
the member states to make sure that that
these kind of problems don't occur in
the future anymore
good afternoon one question to the
president
of the european commission is it
possible that the recovery and
resilience plan or a similar program
will be re-implemented in the future
whether
it is
one-off
i think that
many ordinary citizens still have doubts
about this in finland thank you very
much yes thank you very much um so
we had and have an unprecedented crisis
with the pandemic
and the lockdowns and the paralyzing of
our economy and thus this unprecedented
crisis needed an unprecedented answer
but the
one off is built in
if i may say so
so therefore this is in itself an agreed
system
what we will focus now on is delivery
and implementation this is the 21st
um recovering resilience plan so we're
almost done with designing the plans and
they are designed by the member states
with the objectives we agree on the
european union this is the green deal it
is digitalization its resilience and now
it's a lot about implementation
implementation implementation we have
the milestones the targets and this will
bring the european union and the single
market forward
another question to the president of
commission uh economy is now forecast to
grow by uh 4.8
this year and 4.5 percent next year in
the eu and
euro area
why do we need to stimulate the growth
more with this massive package
why the economy is growing very strongly
in the eu and europe area why do we need
this massive
massive stimulus package yes because
what we've seen with of course the
economy is growing because it has been
shrinking so much
so if you lower the level
where you start the
jump forward is a big one but we've lost
a lot of economic power over the
pandemic that's the one point the second
point is
as you know now reshaping the world the
whole world has to get back into its
economy we see
that
a lot of supply chains have been cut
a lot of businesses have gone out of
business have gone bust
so what we do now is we invest
in a way that with the recovery we
always have also have the leap forward
into modernization of our economy and
therefore we were very strict
that the agreed amount of investment has
to go as i said in the european green
deal
37 of the whole package goes straight
into the european green deal and green
projects so important to invest in this
transition 20 at least have to go into
the digital and you see here in finland
finland has even invested more in the
green and even invested more in the
digital
and a certain portion has to go into the
resilience which is improving our single
market
so we use the time starting low
in the crisis to really jump forward and
modernize and to be come out stronger
out of the crisis then we went into the
crisis
i i agree with ursula it's not only
about financial tool it's actually the
way we build our economies from the
bottom up so we are now transforming our
economies
to the more green more digital so it's
much more than just the stimulus package
it's to do with our our basic economies
and and to build our societies in a new
way
can i perhaps add an example i learned
so much here with quantum computing also
what you invest this is just the right
thing to do
because today
we are defining whether we're going to
be
world leaders or at least competitive in
the quantum computing age
or whether we're going to lag behind
and we see that a lot of investment is
needed to modernize
the same as for example the lack of
semiconductors we see at the moment
being so we want to create an ecosystem
that really works to
get us more independent of the pro in
the production of semiconductors because
we know it's desperately needed for our
economy
we have sectors where the production is
slowed down because of lack of
semiconductors
so this modernizing is crucial to be
competitive also in 10 years and in 20
years
female is one of the eight member states
that have signed a letter critical to
loosening the eu rules on deficit and
public debt did you discuss the issue
today and what are your opinions on
reforming the fiscal rules including the
stability and growth pact thank you yeah
the stability and growth pact important
will be in the fall
to have a common diagnosis
what is the situation of the economy
right now what is the fiscal um
what are the fiscal circumstances we
have right now and for me it's very
important really to listen to all and to
find a consensus that we build within
the european union so it's time now for
the diagnosis
are of course
waiting the commission's proposals
on this finland
once
to make sure that the european economy
in every member states is a sustainable
path and that's why we have sent the
letter to commission but now we're
waiting for the commercial proposals and
we are always open to discuss but still
still we need to make sure that our
economies are are in the solid ground in
the future thank you very much prime
minister thank you very much president
of the commission thank you everyone and
have a very nice evening